Produktaussensioner skrivna med versaler.
Man får ju bara stora bokstäver, allting.
Man skriker ut sina recensioner.
Fan vilken brödprodukt!
Men jag bara undrar, är det för att det ska vara såhär...
Det här är ju inte favoritsegment i den här podden någonsin.
Make Sweden Stronger Man är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Välkommen till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Idag sitter vi här med Wilhelm Sporrång, som är vd på GameFera, och flera av er känner säkert igen honom, eftersom han...
Ja, han var ju en framgångsrik vd redan från ung ålder.
Välkommen till podden, och hur känns det att vara ultra-hypad redan när man var...
Ja, när jag inte hade gjort någonting annat med mitt liv än att typ jobba på ICA?
Tack för det.
Ja, men det stämmer.
Den bilden stämmer nog inte riktigt.
Att jag var inte så hyper.
Men vi är runt omkring...
Du var vd för webbhallen, och när blev du vd där?
Alltså jag kommer inte att bli en till i år.
Jag har sagt det en miljard gånger, men jag tror att det var 2009.
Så jag började på webbhallen 2005, då var jag 25.
Och sen så blev jag vd 2009.
Ja men 2009, då stod jag på ett trim och städade fortfarande, då städade jag alltid toaletterna på kvällen och rensade ur avloppen där.
Så det var när jag var 29, det var vad jag hade måste ha kommit av.
Jag städade också toaletter och rensade avloppen när jag var 29 och var vd.
Då fick du it-killar och det är inte rätt folk att städa efter.
Jag tror inte det var så stor skillnad egentligen.
Jag förstår, jag förstår.
Den här hajpen vet jag inte, det är jättekul att säga det men det stämmer nog inte alls.
Det var ingen som upplevde någon hajp överhuvudtaget, utan det var ingen som visste vilka vi var överhuvudtaget.
Det var nog långt senare som folk började veta vad webballen var för någonting.
När blev det etablerat?
Jag brukar inte prata så mycket om dåtid, men i just det här fallet tycker jag att det är intressant.
För jag kan tycka att det nuvarande bolaget och Gamifiera lite grann känns som att det här stammar från tankar som kom från webbhalventiden.
Jag kanske har helt fel, men jag tycker att den resan är intressant och jag tycker att det är så olika resor, vilket också är väldigt intressant.
Men när blev ni tagna på allvar?
Jag vet inte, men det var ju alltid liksom...
Jag var ju taggad på att bygga någonting stort, någonting som var fantastiskt, som alla skulle älska, och någonting som var till för vår kärnogrupp.
Jag gillade verkligen våra kunder.
Jag var själv i den här extrema datanörden som alltid hade känt mig out of place.
Sen hittade man hem och hittade massa likasinnade och förstod att det var okej att inte gilla fotboll och sånt.
Det var okej att bara gilla tv-spel och datorer.
Det var det enda som var intressant, de grejerna.
Och film och musik.
Jag var sjukt taggad.
Jag ville visa det för alla.
Jag ville att det skulle funka för den breda massa.
Jag ville att det inte bara skulle vara till för de här, inte bara kärnmålgruppen, men det skulle funka för alla.
Även den äldre målgruppen och svensson människor.
Då kände jag att vi hade en chans att bevisa hur bra vi är, vårt koncept, speciellt butikskonceptet och omnikonceptet, och visa upp det i de här stora gallerierna.
Så det var väl så det började egentligen.
Jag tror att det var en stor förändring när vi öppnade i Tärby centrum till exempel.
Är du från Tärby främst?
Nej, jag är från Göteborg.
Ja exakt, jag är västkustpojk.
Dialekten låt Tärby killa näskan.
Nej men det var nog det.
Jag var sjukt taggad på det där och det hade aldrig gått om inte vi fick chansen att visa upp oss där.
Vi fick den av de stora fastighetsägarena som äger Tärby centrum och Målovskan och Scandinavia, Kista gallerier och de här.
Det var ganska mycket på grund av att vårt segment hade försvunnit på många ställen från de stora handelsplatserna och köpcentrum.
Det fanns on-off och expert gick omkull däromkring.
De fanns i de stora gallerierna och sen plötsligt så fanns det ingenting.
Då hörde jag av mig till de här olika ställena och då hade jag väl tur att vi fick chansen att fylla det här vakuumet som hade uppstått i gallerierna.
Det tror jag hade jättestor effekt.
Jag tror att då såg väldigt många normala människor att det här är skitsbra.
Men jag tror att de uppskattade den kundeupplevelsen.
Det var väldigt tydligt och enkelt att förstå.
Och absolut extremt transparent.
Det var ju en väldigt stor grej i det här med att alla skulle känna sig välkomna och det skulle vara samma förutsättningar för alla.
Man skulle inte känna att man behöver vara medlem i någonting för att få rätt pris.
Så det känner du igen, det är säkert samma tankssätt som du har kört på.
Upplever jag i alla fall.
Exakt.
Men var det det som var mer konkret, som du säger, experter och något, de hade ju precis lämnat liksom.
Vad var det ni kom in och gjorde annorlunda och du säger transparent, men vad innebär det förutom att man inte har det?
Det jag menade just där var väl att, jag var ju mest intresserad av den här fysiska kundupplevelsen.
Jag var inte alls lika intresserad på den tiden av online.
Jag tyckte inte att det var särskilt spännande liksom.
Just då så känner jag att här kan vi göra väldigt stor skillnad.
Den fysiska kundupplevelsen är dålig.
Alltså de flesta gör det väldigt dåligt.
De tänker inte på vad det är som gör att människor vill komma tillbaka till en fysisk butik.
Där känner jag att de flesta misslyckades.
För att jag handlade mycket var det mycket i retail.
Jag var inte nöjd med kundupplevelsen.
Jag har tjatat om det mycket.
Jag känner mig som en trasig LP-skiva.
Det här som fortfarande används väldigt mycket i retail.
Om du är medlem, vill du bli medlem nu, det blir bättre priser om du är medlem.
All den här kontakten man har med kunderna använder du till det här tjatet om att försöka tvinga in någon i ett medlemssystem som ingen bryr sig om.
Alla kunder är medlemmar i alla system, men ingen bryr sig.
Jag fattar inte det här.
Vi fokuserade helt och hållet på att ge en bra upplevelse som gör att folk vill komma tillbaka till våra butiker.
Det var ganska enkelt, eftersom det var bara att inte göra det som alla andra gjorde egentligen.
Jag vill inte att våra säljare skulle tjata om uppsälj överhuvudtaget, och de skulle inte tjata om alls om att bli medlemmar.
Vi sålde inga försäkringar, det tyckte jag var jätteosoft.
Med produktförsäkringar, det känns inte...
Jag kan verkligen känna den.
När man går in och handlar någonting så har man nästan ångest för att man vet att nu ska vi snacka försäkringar i typ fem minuter.
Det är fortfarande så i de här...
Och det vi gjorde annorlunda, mina säljare, de...
I köpögonblicket.
Så de var sig själva, liksom ingen mer med det.
De rekommenderade produkter som de gillade.
Och jag tror det är värt så jävla mycket att bara höra, den här produkten som du har valt här, den är skitbra.
Jag har den själv, eller vi säljer jättemycket av den och den är jättebra.
Och det är så jävla enkelt och det är så mycket bättre upplevelse och det gör att den här kunden känner, fan det här var bra, här handlar det nästa gång.
Det var också en stor grej med konceptet att istället för att vara begränsad av utrymmet man har i ens butiksyta, som våra konkurrenter hade, de hade alla produkter framme i butikerna, då blir det ju enkelt så att du har grejerna med hög marginal.
Det är de du försöker sälja, såklart.
Men vi hade inte det problemet, vi lade ju allting bakom disk, så vi var extremt späckade butiker bakom, men ingenting i butiksytan.
Och tanken var ju där, vi ska inte begränsa våra säljare på något sätt, utan de ska kunna sälja vad som helst, och kunderna ska få det de vill ha, för de grejerna har vi i lager.
Och vi kände att man behöver inte visa en samsung tv.
Alla vet hur en samsung tv ser ut, och du säljer dem på spes och på recensioner, är det 4k, är det HDR och så vidare, det är det som spelar roll.
Folk vill inte se en dammig samsung tv på en sån här stor vägg.
Jag köper ju allting du säger, för jag funkar ju på det sättet, men det finns ju ändå en sorts motseelse i att man visar inte upp saker, utan man kommer till en disk och så måste man prata med någon, och så ska det vara folk som står där eller man ska vänta.
Hur upplevde du den blockaden?
Jag tycker det är nice, men jag vet inte om det är någon bokstavskombination, men jag tycker att det är härligt när det är väldigt tydligt vad som gäller.
Jag vill inte gå och leta i en butik, och jag vill inte gå och leta efter en person som kan hjälpa mig.
Det tycker jag är skitirriterande.
Jag vill ju mycket hellre ta nummerlapp, och bara nu är det din tur och så kommer du och så får jag hjälp.
Och så får den här personen gå och hämta det du ska ha åt dig.
Det känns som ett bra service tycker jag.
Men byggde för rätt många butikskedjor och koncept är ju inte uppbyggda så.
Byggde du det här konceptet på vad du tyckte var nice, eller på att du tänkte att det här finns en riktig lucka, om du är riktigt ärlig.
Allting hänger ihop, jag älskade det själv.
Jag jämförde det med hur andra gjorde.
Vi såg att det funkade, och det var väldigt mycket omni-grejen också.
Vi var extremt tidiga med det.
Vi såg hur bra man kunde kränga när sajten funkade.
Den användes för all form av efterforskning.
Alla produkter fanns där, alla produktresensioner som var skitviktiga, spesar och allting liksom.
Och där såg du lagerstatus per butik.
Så vi såg exakt hur många det fanns i varje butik.
Och vi märkte skitidigt att de här gröna bockarna i butikerna och lagerstatusen, den är så jävla viktig.
Du säljer ingenting i butikerna om inte grejerna finns i lager.
Då läggs det inga order så då kommer det inga kunder liksom.
Så tillgängligheten var ju jätteviktig verkligen.
Och det var ju när jag slutade, vi omsatte två miljarder när jag slutade, hälften av det var nog renodlad, klicken, collect som du kallar det.
Vad var liksom anledningen där?
För att det är ju uppenbart att detta är någonting du ändå tycker är intressant.
Eller du pratar ju som att du går igång lite grann på det.
Det är ett ganska stort steg att helt plötsligt starta ett nytt bolag.
Men jag fick sparken.
Efter den resan?
Ja men så är det.
Du hamnar ju, jag var ju där länge liksom.
Det som händer är väl att folk får väl sparken?
Vd-ar får väl sparken?
Jo det kanske de får, men inte om man går från 100 miljoner till 2 miljarder får man väl lite sparken.
Okej om man går från 2 miljarder till 100 miljoner, det är en helt annan situation.
Det var så jag trodde också.
Hur otrevlig är du i verkligheten?
Det är det som är grejen.
Jag trodde ju att när man gör en sån här grej, och allting funkar så här bra, man känner att man är för hybris.
Man bygger upp någonting som man tycker är helt fantastiskt.
Man känner att det här är ju, jag är en så stor del i det här.
Det är inte så att jag inte trodde att de andra var det, men de var ju mycket bättre än vad jag var.
Mina medarbetare, det var ju hela grejen.
Det enda jag var bra på var att samla de här fantastiskt duktiga människorna.
Men man får ju ändå en hybris och man tror att man är oersättlig.
Sedan börjar det handla om pengar och man är inte överens med styrelser och grejer och då är det kört, då får man sparken.
Det finns absolut inget roll nu, det är vatten under bron, helt och hållet.
Men det var ju också så, jag kanske inte hade fått sparken om det inte var så att vi började få lite röda siffror.
Vi gjorde ju en ganska kraftig expansion strax innan jag slutade.
Jag kommer inte ihåg hur många, men det handlade väldigt mycket om tillväxt.
Och jag ville ju driva den här skapande tillväxten med butiköppningar.
För omni-affären var ju så bra och jag kände att vi behöver öppna fler butiker så vi öppnade på ganska kort tid många butiker.
Och det var samma veva som kemikalier, skatter och grejer, om du har koll på det.
Så det var...
Viktiga tillväxtkategorier gick plötsligt ganska mycket sämre.
Till exempel TV gick ganska dåligt, vi hade inte alls någon tillväxt längre.
Och då blev det lite svarta siffror på grund av de här ökade kostnaderna.
Väldigt kortsiktigt skulle jag säga.
Jag såg det inte som ett stort problem.
Jag tror att det här kommer att repa sig, men jag fick gå.
Okej, fick du någon sorts idé?
Du verkar inte chockad av min ärlighet här.
Jag trodde hela grejen att man skulle vara ärlig med.
Ja men det är härligt, folk brukar inte vara ärliga, det är väl underbart.
Jag är väldigt glad, helt plötsligt.
Det är en lobbyupplevelse men det...
Då är det jobb kvar.
Ja exakt, exakt.
Du får också sparka snart.
Någon gång ska jag väl få det.
Ja men vad, jag är ju också lite frispråkig, när du fick lämna, för detta var ändå en, som du beskriver det, man kan få lite hybris eller man går ju in i det och det blir ju ens egna projekt och sen behöver man lämna och så bara, vad fan ska man göra nu?
Fick du någon sorts identitetskris där?
Du är ju fortfarande väldigt ung i den här situationen.
Jag är mest fascinerad över den delen, för då måste du ha varit typ 38 eller något när du vill lämna, var det inte nio år eller någonting?
Jo men det är inte så jävla ungt.
Ja okej.
Jag känner mig nog som hundra, 38, etc.
Nej men jag fick absolut en identitetskris.
Jag hade ju verkligen levt i det där dygnet runt i så många år liksom och det var ju människor som jag tyckte om väldigt, väldigt mycket.
Så det var ju helt klart som en familj för mig.
Och sen bara blev det liksom avklippt på direkt verkligen.
Det var ju helt sjukt.
Det var helt sjukt.
Så jag mådde ganska dåligt där men det var inte jättelänge ska jag inte säga.
Men i kort tid så hade jag, jag kommer ihåg att jag vaknade mitt i natten där.
Första natten så vaknade jag och allting bara snurrade du vet.
Och man vet ju, jag har haft liksom föräldrar som haft strokes och grejer och jag kände att det här nu, det här är stroke.
Det är en stroke liksom.
Men det var ju inte det utan det var ju bara någon form av, jag vet fortfarande inte hur fan det är möjligt liksom.
Det var inget fysiskt fel med mig alls men allting bara, allt bara snurrade.
Någon form av panikkänsla liksom.
Jag kommer ihåg att mina, för mig var det ändå ganska lugnt men jag kommer ihåg mina barn.
Jag hade två döttrar då som var, även de gamla barnen kanske var åttaårsåldern.
De blev skitlästna av någon anledning.
Storböla av det här att jag hade slutat på webballen.
Jag vet inte om identiteten var, för de var så stark för hela min familj.
Den här kopplingen.
Jättekonstigt.
Jag kan förstå det för mina barn är ju väldigt, de ser ju mig som gymkompani, trots att de bara är tre och fyra.
De kan ju se, om de ser våran logga eller de ser till och med en bil som är ungefär som min bil så är det en gymkompani, ett bi.
Alltså de är väldigt så.
Det hade varit för dem som att jag slutade vara Joel nästan.
Ja men då kanske det är rimligt då, att det är så.
Men vad hände sen där då?
Vad var det som ledde fram till nästa steg?
Hur började tankarna komma igång?
Ja, vad fan är det som hände sen?
Alltså jag var ju ledd i ett tag där, inte jättelänge men kanske sex månader.
Det var ju en intressant tid på många sätt.
Efterhand var det en väldigt härlig tid.
Att inte ha någonting att göra alls, utan bara vara med sina barn.
Det enda jag gjorde var att lämna och hämta på dagis.
Det är så jag ser det nu i efterhand, det var det jag gjorde.
Ta promenader och hämta och lämna det på dagis.
Det som händer är att man kommer ner på jorden väldigt snabbt.
Från att tro att man är bäst på allting så är man, kanske inte sämst på allt, men man är ganska dålig på allting.
Men det var viktigt, jag tror det var viktigt.
Jag behövde det och jag hade säkert behövt det tidigare.
Efterhans hade jag säkert kunnat få den lektionen lite tidigare.
Vad som hände sen, det var väl att jag blev, jag var ju jättetaggad på att starta någonting nytt såklart.
Och jag hade ju, jag...
Nej, varför var det, nu säger du såklart, varför var du jättesugn på att starta något nytt såklart?
Det är inte helt givet.
Är inte det?
Nej, när man har gjort en sån här så blir det kanske så här, folk går in i någon sorts, ja vad ska jag göra nu?
Och så tar man två år och hoppar runt och flummar lite och konsultar någonstans i en kvart och sen.
Men absolut.
Jag kände mig inte klara såklart liksom.
Utan jag var skittaggad.
Och den här grejen som vi gjorde på webbalängaren, jag vet inte om det var 2014, men jag tyckte det var jävligt hett.
Men jag gillade ju butiksgrejen, men sen steget efter det där, det blev ju att fokusera på kundupplevelsen online.
Och då gjorde vi de här grejerna som på många sätt ligger till grund för det som vi gör nu på Gameifyera.
Och det är att vi byggde ett gamifierat lojalitetssystem.
Alltså vi byggde ju, gick bort från det här med rabatter och återbärgande grejer.
Inte för att vi höll på med det innan heller liksom, men vi ville ju bygga något som på riktigt drev engagemang och som gjorde att våra kunder kom tillbaka till oss oftare och var hos oss.
Och då låg det ju nära till hands att göra någonting med gamification.
På den tiden så var ju Xbox 360, där fanns det en massa achievements och gamification.
Vi märkte att det funkade på oss och vi tänkte att det här måste funka på våra kunder också.
Att man får digitala belöningar för att man gör olika saker hos oss.
Så det byggde vi ju det här achievements-systemet och med levels och progress bars och grejer.
Sedan ville vi ha någon form av avatarrer för alla kunder.
Tanken där var att man skulle bygga sig själv inom vårt varumärke, i vår värld, för att öka känslan av samhörighet och den typen av grejer.
Man blir en del av vår värld, en del av något större.
Det låter skittöntigt för dig.
Jag ser det på dig.
Jag är väldigt fascinerad av det här.
Detta är ju det folk snackar om nu.
Det är ju...
En av frågorna jag ville ställa var, var ni sjukt typ för tidiga med Game of Era när ni drog igång detta?
Det känns som att då var det en sådan här, ja det här borde man göra men ingen riktigt fattade vad man skulle göra.
Nu känns det som att folk känner att, fan vi har missat bollen nästan.
Det har liksom inte på något sätt levlat.
Det känns som att väldigt många pratar om att bygga community, och gamifiera upplevelsen och bygga en, det ska inte bara handla om rabatten men det känns inte riktigt som att folk har liksom fattat det än eller dratt igång det och jag fattar inte heller.
Det är därför detta är intressant.
Tycker du att e-handeln har fattat detta?
Nej.
Jo.
Men inte dina kunder såklart.
Jag är så inne i den här bubblan.
Vi har ju så jävla fina kunder nu.
Vi har Stadium och Servera och Jolleroom.
Och Inet och ni är så stora, fina kunder.
De är fantastiska, de fattar ju det här.
Men det här är ju ultraetablerade.
När jag kollar igenom er kundlista så har ni ju...
Ni har ju inte de här nyaste trendbolagen och ni har inte heller de här gamla slöfockarna.
Utan ni har liksom...
Det känns som att ni har tagit den etablerade aktören i varje nisch lite grann.
Om man säger, som du säger Jolly Room, då är det såhär, ja, inom barnsegmentet, vilka är det du tänker på, vilka är liksom first thought typ eller stadium, eller ni har ju gymmagrosisten till exempel, inom kosttillskott och liknande.
Men alla andra då?
De andra 8000 bolagen, varför gör inte de det här?
Är det för att vi är för små alla vi andra?
Kan inte vi bygga det här ekosystemet?
Är det ingen som bryr sig om oss liksom?
Saker tar ju sån jävla tid, märker inte du det?
Det tar så mycket längre tid än man vill och tror att det ska göra.
Men det tar lång tid.
Men när det gäller...
Sverige är så jävla liten, jättelitet liksom.
Det är pyttelitet.
Om du kollar på topplistan, största e-handlarna, de som är på topp 100 omsätter mindre än vad du gör.
Du är väl topp 100 i Sverige liksom?
Nej, jag tror inte jag är där än faktiskt.
Det finns mycket skumma grejer.
Det finns mycket skumma grejer, ja jo.
Nej men, det handlar väl om att...
För oss har det ju väldigt mycket varit så att vi blev tidigt inriktade mot ganska stora e-handlare och retailers.
Hur gick de dialogerna?
Vad var det du sålde in?
Jag är sjukt intresserad av hur det här drog igång.
Men grejen är att...
Det berodde ju på att vi fick så mycket intresse på grund av att det var buzzwords med Game of Crasia antar jag och den typen av grejer.
Och det visade sig att stora företag hade koll på den här grejen vi byggde på webbhallen.
De tyckte att det var att det...
Många såg det faktiskt som någon form av förebild för hur man...
Så här ska man bygga lojalitet liksom.
Det är inte med rabatter och återbanger utan det är genom att aktivera hans kunder och engagera dem på det här sättet.
Så vi blev kontaktade av många stora företag precis i början.
När vi bara var liksom några veckor gamla och knappt hade någon produkt alls liksom så blev vi kontaktade av stora företag.
Då fick jag tillbaka min hybris såklart och då kände jag att nu, okej det är lugnt, nu kommer vi att ha Ica och Ikea här direkt och så är det klart liksom.
Och så sa min CT och nu men fan de här stora, kommer inte det ta väldigt lång tid de processerna tror du?
Nej, nej nej det är lugnt.
Det är lugnt.
Ja men ska vi inte rikt in oss på alla de här små?
Det finns väldigt många fler små e-handlare som sitter på Shopify.
Är inte det bättre att ha en miljon sådana kunder än att ha?
Du vet jag.
Men vi blev inriktade på stora ganska tidigt och det är ju långa processer absolut.
Och vi har egentligen bara rört oss i Sverige och Norden skulle jag säga.
Och det är ungefär för något år sedan som vi började bygga vår ordentliga integration mot Shopify.
Och det är ju för att bli tillgängliga för väldigt många i alla fall.
Men det handlar jättemycket om att göra funktionaliteten enklare att integrera.
Och det är ju liksom Shopify-integrationen är superenkel.
Men det ska även vara enkelt för e-handlare som inte har Shopify.
Hur liten man än är liksom.
Men det har ju varit en tröskel där för att det har krävs arbete för att integrera och det har innebär kostnader från olika håll.
Alltså sitter man på en tredjeparts plattform så är det ju, de ska också göra grejer då liksom och de ska ha betalt och så vidare.
Men är det det som är den stora stoppklossen i folks huvud för att detta är ju, nu använder ju inte vi till exempel någon gemifering men jag funderar på vad som är mina blockader mot att göra det men vad är din bedömning av att varför har inte folk det här på sin sajt så som ni jobbar med era kunder för det är ju väldigt logiskt.
Men det är inte konstigt.
Jag är förvånad att du tycker det är konstigt.
Tull att vi sitter i motsatta riktningar.
Det är ju någonting helt nytt liksom.
Det är fortfarande, även fast jag har gått ett par år, men det är ju fortfarande någonting som är nytt liksom.
Och det är ju min lärdom av de här åren vi har hållit på med här, det är att alla vill vara ensamma om saker och de säger att de vill vara först med saker.
Men det är ju egentligen väldigt få som vågar vara först om någonting liksom.
Och det blir väldigt mycket enklare att hoppa på när man har en, någon annan i samma segment som har gjort det här.
Då ser man att vi måste också göra det här.
Och det gäller väl säkert all funktionalitet som är standard idag.
Det är väl någon som varit först med ratings och reviews också.
Och det tar tid innan alla fattar.
Det är fortfarande inte alla e-handlare som har ratings och reviews.
Och vet inte än om det, behöver vi det, är det rätt?
Kommer vi få tillräckligt mycket eller kommer vi ha för lite recensioner?
Kommer det bara se löjligt ut liksom?
Men kan inte du förklara vad er koncept är då?
Vad är det ni på riktigt liksom, om man går ner på ground level, vad är det egentligen er tjänst gör?
Nu blir det som en form av säljpitch här.
Ja men jag kan säga, vad tredje mening kan jag säga, fan det låter cash, så låter det inte så säljigt då.
Okej men det handlar ju väldigt mycket om att engagera ens kunder och skapa nya incitament för ens kunder att logga in på en sajt och bli medlemmar och komma tillbaka oftare.
Game of Cache handlar jättemycket om att belöna en användare för att göra saker som de kanske inte annars hade gjort.
Det handlar inte om pengar och sånt, utan det handlar om emotionella belöningar, emotionella drivkrafter.
Det är samma drivkrafter som man använder i alla typer av spel.
Man får en liten typ pling, du kan byta mask eller något sånt där.
Är det så?
Byta mask?
Nej men så här, här du får byta kläder på din avatar nu för du har gett tre recensioner.
Är det liksom så det funkar?
Ja, det är väl så det är.
Men det handlar ju väldigt mycket om, alltså det enklaste exemplet är ju att ge ut en badge till någon som har gjort någonting.
Nu har du recenserat fem gånger, då fick du den här badgen när du är en top reviewer eller något sådant där liksom.
Du fick någonting för det och så ser man om du också gör det här, då kommer du att få den här badgen och om du gör det här så får du det här.
Den typen av enkla grejer kommer innebära att fler användare gör de här sakerna som du vill att de ska göra än vad det var innan.
Det är inte färre, det är garanterat fler.
Det beror lite på hur många fler det är, det beror lite på hur bra du gör det.
Men det är ju gamification.
Det handlar ofta om att göra någonting som är tråkigt, att göra det roligare än vad det var innan.
Sen kan du göra det väldigt olika avancerat och väldigt olika bra.
Om du även lyckas anspela på någon form av ägarskap och någon form av bekräftelse och någon form av att du kan jämföra dig med andra av den typen av bivkrafter, då blir det ju ännu bättre.
Hur bygger ni upp det?
Hur skapar ni den möjligheten?
Är det att man ser att det här är topp 10, reviewers, eller hur får folk känna att de är bäst?
Det är på många olika sätt, men ett sätt är ju att du ger ut sådana här digitala belöningar på olika sätt.
Du skapar kanske uppdrag som är att den här veckan, om du recenserar någonting den här veckan, så händer det här eller så får du det här.
Det kanske är kopplat till traditionella bonuspoäng, så att bonuspoäng är så att till ens kunder inte bara baserat på hur mycket pengar de spenderar, utan även hur engagerade de är, och hur mycket content de bidrar med.
Du kan ha topplister som du var inne på, det kan absolut vara jättebra.
Man kan gå in på varandras profiler och jämföra sig med andra, att du lyfter upp en person som har blivit uppvotad x antal gånger, kommer högre upp på en produktsida.
Det finns massor man kan göra.
Jag säger inte att alla gör allt, absolut inte.
Om man kollar på våra kunder så är det väldigt olika hur man använder dem.
Men det blir ju effekterna är stora.
Lägsta nivån är högre skulle jag säga.
Jag kan bli så jävla sur på detta.
Jag är rätt pessimistisk som person, och låtsas att jag är i alla fall rationell.
Och så kan jag bli skitsur på att ska jag få en jävla pling-badge och så ska det göra att jag går in och hjälper en av företagarna.
Vänta, jag måste få säga färdigt.
Men jag får ju...
Jag reviewar ibland om jag är på en restaurang, eller hotell eller någonting så skriver jag ju.
Och Google skickar till mig hej du är topp blablabla reviewers och nu har 5000 personer sett din jävla review.
Och det går jag ju igång lite på.
Och så reviewar jag ju någonting nytt den dagen bara för att de har skickat.
Det är ju skitlöjligt kan jag tycka på ett personligt par.
Men det funkar ju.
Ja men jag kan bara bli fascinerad över att fan jag har två unga, jag sitter och jobbar och jag har åtta jobbsamtal den dagen.
Och så kommer det en liten pling om att någon människa jag inte har sett har likat en grej jag skrev för nio månader sedan om en restaurang i typ Upplands Väsby.
Och så blir jag såhär, ja fan då måste jag göra och reuva lunchrepubliken här i Mönnlycke.
Alltså det är så ologiskt i mitt huvud men jag gör ju det, det funkar ju.
Är vi så jävla simpla som människor?
Svart om.
Det hade varit simpelt om du inte.
Ja okej, fair enough.
Men folk vill se sig själv som ultra rationella.
Det är typ, jag tror man skäms över att vara irrationell, men människor är inte rationella.
Det är det som är grejen.
Vi styrs inte av rationella saker, utan det är väldigt irrationellt det man går igång på.
Och det är ju hela livet.
Det handlar inte bara om hur vi beter oss online, utan det är ju allting liksom.
Jag vill bara fråga, den här lösningen som ni då tillhandahållit, du sa att folk använder den på väldigt olika sätt.
Är det så att ni sitter med kunder och pratar och tar fram någonting för dem, eller har ni ett koncept och så loggar man in i det och checkar in, och så använder man det.
Hur sker processen och hur mycket är ni delaktiga i att ta fram företags, vad ska vi kalla det då, gamification process eller community aspekt?
Vad är er roll, är ni bara mjukvara eller är ni också konsulter?
Produkten ändras hela tiden och utvecklas, men det finns ju en färdig produkt som man kan använda rakt av mer eller mindre.
Det som behöver anpassas då är styling och färger och fonts.
Det är meningen att det ska vara extremt enkelt för vem som helst.
Nu låter det extremt sälligt här.
Jag får inga protester från din.
Usch, vad simpelt det låter.
Det är skitsimpligt.
Vi har även gjort det avancerat med flera kunder.
Det går att integrera både via widgets och API.
Våra priser är väldigt förmånliga just nu.
Det går att göra på väldigt många olika sätt.
Det handlar om att vi försöker fortfarande hitta det som funkar bäst.
Just nu är det mycket fokus på att göra det väldigt enkelt och integrera och minska trösklar egentligen.
Sedan kan man bygga vidare på det i efterhand.
Om du kollar på Inet, du har ju koll på Inet.
Jag har en säljare därifrån som har börjat hos oss.
Han jämför alltid med Inet.
Han säger alltid att vi gjorde så här på Inet.
Håll käften, du har såss nu så skit i Inet nu.
Ni är nog lika på många, men de är ju skitduktiga också.
De är så jävla bra.
Vår integration där, allting är gjort 100% med API där.
För att de vill att det ska se ut exakt på deras vis.
De ska full kontroll på allting.
Så kan man ju göra, men de flesta har ju inte gjort så.
De flesta väljer att hålla det enklare integrationsmässigt för att inte blanda in för mycket folk och att det inte ska ta för lång tid.
Så om du håller det enkelt kan du göra en integration på en vecka.
Finns det några branscher som är riktigt kassa på vad ska vi säga, kundupplevelse eller kundlojalitet eller kundkommunitet?
Då finns det vissa branscher där du tycker att de har lyckats eller är bara alla så här här är 10% på vårt nyhetsbrev och nu spämmer vi dig.
Men det är så, även då man kan säga att det är en viss bransch, vad tycker du själv där?
Är det någon bransch som är värre än andra branscher?
Jag tycker mord är bedrövliga, men jag tycker att ja, fan finns det någon som är bra?
Jag vet inte, det känns ju hemskt.
Nej jag vet inte om jag tycker någon är riktigt bra.
Men vad är de dåliga på mordor då?
Vad är det som är dåligt?
Om jag går in på en sajt för första gången, som jag aldrig har varit på och jag har kommit in på den sajten, så börjar det ju med att här får du 15 procent.
Och sen så köper jag ju oftast strumpor, alltså det är ju typ det jag köper.
Och sen får jag fyra mejl i vecka om alla möjliga kläder som jag är helt ointresserad av och det är sådana här hej min kära kund, det är bara att vi är och jag är inte din kära kund, jag köper svarta strumpor där.
Vi saknar dig.
Exakt.
Har du kollat till min ens, vi saknar dig mejl då, jag gjorde det någon gång i min inkorg.
För jag är ju medlem i alla kundklubbar.
Jag är jättesvård för det där också, men jag tror inte att det är någon speciell bransch som är...
Jag vet inte, men det där med att behandla första gångskunden bäst, det har ju varit standard ganska länge och det är ju jättekonstigt tycker jag.
Att du behandlar de i lojala allra bäst, och de som är lojala, de är redan inne med den kunder, vi behöver inte göra någonting där.
De ska få betala extra pris, men den som handlar första gången, de ska ha 75 procent rabatt.
Och så är man öppen med det också.
Alla ser det här, de lojala kunderna ser att de i lojala får bäst pris.
Det är jättekonstigt.
Men allt tar sin tid.
Det handlar jättemycket om datadrivenhet.
Det är säkert en grej i det att man, det har ju fått sån jävla fokus, att man är så stolt över att vara så datadriven, att man förstår data.
Men vi har mycket data, vi förstår den.
Vi ser att den här, när vi ger 25% till de som handlar första gången, då är det så här många som handlar.
Det ger den här omsättningen.
Det är såklart att det är positivt, jättepositivt.
Det ska vi fortsätta med och vi måste göra det här mer.
Men det är helt omöjligt att mäta hur det påverkar de riktiga kunderna, de lojala kunderna.
Hur påverkade de, hur arga blev de och hur påverkade det varumärket när varumärket ses som en återställare som man bara går till om man får rabatt eller rabattkupong.
Det är inte där man kommer att handla automatiskt nästa gång utan man väntar på någon form av rabatt.
Du hade meddelat att tverserna har varit tvers.
Är det inte mycket på grund av marginaler?
Jo, det är väl klart.
Det här med reor och sånt där, fashion har väl varit en stor grej i det här med att där är det ofta, det kan vara 50% och upp till 75%.
Konstantin har väl lärt sig att fashion har 75% marginal på sina produkter.
De flesta vet säkert att det inte finns det på iPhones.
De har inte 75% marginal där utan det är 5% max.
Men då väntar man väl, man väntar väl med att handla till sådär.
Det ska vara minst 50% rabatt, annars handlar inte jag kläde.
Det har kanske blivit så.
Ja jag tror att det är så men jag tänkte säga...
Jag såg att du skrev om det här med rabattkoder, specifika rabattkoder och det är intressant tycker jag.
Det är jättespännande fenomen.
Ja jag har ju väldigt svårt för det.
Det är klart att man får ha reor och att man får aktivera produkter, men jag har väldigt svårt för när man ger olika priser till olika människor.
Den här stora debatten som har varit nu att man får ge, dessutom folk olika priser beroende på vilken ingång de har, om det är Google eller där eller själva.
Jag har väldigt svårt för det att det inte är helt transparent.
Det är kaos.
Det här är dumt att säga, jag vet det för att det är standard.
Jag vet hur vi gjorde på webballen för länge sedan.
Det var rabattkod.
Att ha den i check-outen, att bara ha rabattkodfältet i kassan, det gör att jag som konsument ser att nu ska jag betala, men det finns ett fält här för rabattkoder.
Det är inte nice.
Vill de då att jag ska ge mig ut på nätet och leta efter någon rabattkod?
På ett eller annat sätt gör det att jag känner mig mindre nöjd med det här som jag har lagt i min varukorg än vad jag gjorde innan jag såg rabattkoden.
Var att den finns där.
Den är problematisk tycker jag.
Det sista man borde vilja ge är att folk ska känna så och känna att jag borde ha efterforskat mer, jag borde ha kollat först om det finns någon rabattkod.
Det kommer göra att man blir mindre nöjd med en köp, tror jag, om man tittar på stora massan.
Jag vet inte om folk tycker så här.
Jag var förvånad, när jag läste att du skrev det här så blev jag ändå förvånad.
För då kände jag att det här är inte normalt beteende.
Han är inte normal, alltså.
Nej men jag har hört det någon gång.
Men nu skit i mig nu, det är den stora enda regeln jag har.
Jag hatar att prata med er själv när ni har på den.
Men om vi ska vara kritiska mot er här nu, när ni har varit så sälj...
inte varit så jävla säljigt, men...
Varför är ni inte större som bolag?
Ni har massa branschledare inom respektive segment, och konsensus känns som att folk borde röra sig mot detta.
Vad är er stoppkloss i bolagsbygget här?
Det tar så mycket mer tid än man tror, och det finns så många stoppklossar som man inte har förstått.
Den största har varit hur tillgängligt det är för de mindre e-handlarna, som du var inne på själv.
Det är de stora grejerna.
Och det är ju så bred det blir, när man har fokuserat väldigt mycket på de större e-handlarna och retailbolagen.
Är det för att ni har byggt en produkt som är lite för individuell, snarare än att ni har byggt, ni har inte gjort en klick-and-add, utan är det det ni håller på med nu med Shopify?
Nej, jag tror inte vi förstod hur begränsade resurser man har kanske.
Hur svårt det är att göra de allra minsta sakerna, när man sitter på en 3D-partsplattform kanske.
Och hur mycket integrationer som behöver finnas och så vidare.
Jag tror att det är det som gör att det tar tid.
Därför har vi lagt så mycket tid på att göra vår Shopify-integration.
Den kommer snart att vara klar.
Då blir vi 100% tillgängliga för alla som sitter på Shopify.
Det är säkert 4 miljoner e-handlare.
Då kommer de bara att kunna slå på er tjänst.
Är det så det funkar då?
Ja, då blir det ett plug-in rakt av.
Som du kan en app i Shopify.
Det är det jag tror och hoppas i alla fall.
Det kommer att ha en väldigt stor effekt.
Det finns inte så många stora e-handlare i Sverige.
Helt ärligt också, vi har ju valt att växa organiskt.
Det låter ju jäkligt klyssigt kanske.
Men när vi ska gå ut utanför Norden och in i Europa, vår plan är ju att ha ett case först.
Inte att öppna ett kontor i London.
Det är så vi ska växa i utanför Norden, utan det är att skaffa oss de här jättestarka casen, starka varumärken utanför Norden.
Och vi är ju inte där än, vi har inte ens börjat prata med de företagenslösa.
Vart kikar ni på inspiration?
Det känns ju som att den asiatiska marknaden drar detta stenhårt liksom.
Jag vet inte, vad tänker du på det?
Hela gamification-grejen med, de drar ju det till absurdum för oss som svenskar kanske, men de är ju ändå inne i en miljö där man befinner sig i det ekosystemet mycket mer än vad man gör i svenska e-handlare.
Jag har ju suttit i Alibaba och pratat med asiatiska varumärken till exempel och det blir ju nästan som en community-plattform snarare än någonting annat.
Jag skulle inte säga att vi får någon inspiration från Asien.
Det är fortfarande Xbox och Nintendo som är...
Jag tror att det handlar mycket mer om community.
Då är ju inspirationer från sociala medier mycket mer.
Det är det jag skulle säga.
När det gäller gaming for case, är det den här grejen som man gör...
Är det kylen eller temen som håller på med spinners och grejer?
Jag vet inte vilken av dem, men exakt.
Det känns...
Jag vet inte om det känns superintressant.
Det har inte vi gjort än.
Det är väl bra att ha någon form av överraskningsmoment, men det är lätt att det blir lite syniskt.
Om du får allting att klättsa kring, att bara handla mer och oftare egentligen.
Så det är inte där fokuset ligger, skulle jag säga.
Vilka är det som finansierar bolaget?
För ni har gått minus här ett par år, vilka är det som äger och driver bolaget?
Vi har tagit in några skvättar med pengar.
Initiala investeraren var Wall Street som du kanske känner till.
Nej, men de finns här i Göteborg.
Ja, just det.
Nu är planen att vi ska gå och breakeven, men vi skulle gjort det förra året.
Men i år ska vi ju gå och breakeven.
Helt klart är planen.
Det känns som en skitrolig milstolpa.
Det kommer känna sig jävla roligt.
Tror du hybris kommer tillbaka då?
Jag vet inte, men jag vet också att de här milstolparna förr i tiden, man blev inte så hela glad när det hände.
Alldeles för lite glad egentligen.
Det var alltid direkt fokus på nya problem.
Jag skulle säga att jag uppskattar nog inte tillräckligt när det händer bra saker.
Det är nästan aldrig nöjd med någonting.
Det är bara serbara problem hela tiden.
Vad tycker du?
Får man prata om dig eller är det slut med det?
Nej jag kan väl säga.
Blir du glad när det händer bra saker eller är det bara?
Nej, jag funkar lite på samma sätt faktiskt.
Jag är väldigt, vad ska man säga?
Jag skulle säga att hela min styrka ligger i att se scenarion.
Jag ger ofta upp scenarion för närmsta året och så bygger jag olika vägar där som vi ska röra oss kring då.
När jag är klar med det så blir jag nästan deppig för då har jag ingenting att göra den här hemskta tiden.
Då är alla beslut på ett sätt redan tagna oavsett hur det hamnar.
Sen om vi når en, nu nådde vi det här så känns det som att jag redan upplevt det i huvudet så det är relativt oviktigt.
Alla mål som vi uppnår är såhär, ja det tänkte jag för två och ett halvt år sen så det är ju precis skittråkigt nu.
Det var en bra beskrivning tycker jag.
Om du säger som den här Shopify-kopplingen då så säger jag att när ni slår på den och så går du ut med att nu har vi slagit på den då kommer du få x antal människor som här av sig och bara fan vad stort det här är ju fucking episk.
Så är det såhär, ja fast jag har ju tänkt på detta i två år.
Så att jag har ju redan gått igenom att vi har slått på den.
Och vi har redan gjort AB och C-tester så att jag har redan typ blivit glad en gång och så skett sig det så slog vi på en gång och till.
Och nu är det sista gången när det funkar så är det såhär, ja ja, men om en vecka kanske det skiter sig så.
Det är jättedöppigt, men så funkar mitt tanke i det sättet.
Det är samma här.
Ja, fan vad muntigt.
Ja men man tror ju ändå, jag kommer ihåg på webbalans, jag kommer ihåg att det var när vi gör miljarden då jävlar, då ska vi porka upp champagne.
Men det gjorde man inte liksom.
Jag kommer inte ihåg att jag blev glad alls för det.
Det var bara nu två miljarder.
Men miljarden var ju svårt år.
Den tog tid och det var tufft.
Sen bara rullade det på till två.
Och då var man inte dugglad.
Alltså då fanns det ingen.
Det fanns ingenting liksom.
Jag vet inte, det är tråkigt där.
Det är tråkigt att man inte kan uppskatta.
Men har du redan hamnat i nya tankar?
Vad är du i Gameifyeras resa?
Det behöver inte vara sant eller intressant eller att ni ska här ditt.
Men bara, det har varit intressant att se, hur ser scenariot ut här?
Nej, absolut inga, inga, nej jag har absolut inga tankar på någonting annat än det här.
Alls.
Absolut inte, nej.
På riktigt.
Det har jag inte.
Det här är ju, det är långt ifrån klart, liksom, det här.
Det finns ju, det har alltid funnits väldigt mycket tankar kring den, liksom, större bilden av det.
Det vi gör, det är väldigt mycket, alltså vår produkt är byggd på många sätt för att funka dag ett för alla e-handlare.
Det är någonting som funkar och liksom, ger en massa bra effekter för alla e-handlare direkt, som alla förstår och som alla gillar.
Men det finns ju en större tanke med plattformen som vi inte pratar om, liksom.
För att vi tror inte att den är inte intressant idag.
Okej, men får vi göra det?
De tänker på väldigt mycket.
Jag har pratat med de i förr det också men de är ju, tanken har ju alltid varit att öppna upp det i framtiden.
Vi skulle aldrig göra det såklart på eget bevåg, men nu trycker vi upp det, det kan vi inte göra.
Men jag har alltid trott att i framtiden nån gång så kommer det att vara aktuellt.
Då innebär det att vi öppnar upp ett community som är cross brand, och hur som helst.
Detta blir liksom en shopping, eller vad ska man säga då?
Det skulle bli ett shopping, ett community, ja exakt, ja jag fattar.
Och det skulle du kunna göra så mycket roliga grejer med.
Och när det gäller avataren och du, jag tror inte att du bryr dig så mycket om den, men jag tycker att avataren är väldigt kul.
Jag tycker att jag ser väldigt mycket potential med avataren och sådana digitala assets och hur man bygger sin egen digitala version av sig själv och den typen av grejer.
Jag tycker att det är jättehäftigt.
Och jag har alltid sett att när du går in på din site med din avatar och sen så gör du bra grejer där, så låser du upp era speciella avatardelar och hantlän.
Jag vet inte fan, ni säljer hantlar och dumbbells och den typen av grejer.
Och de får du hos dig.
Men sen har du ju mer i dem när du går in på ICA online med samma avatar.
Och så är Joel inne på ICA, så är du precis lika individuell inne på ICA online som du är fysisk.
Och om du går in i en fysisk butik på ICA, då är ju du det själv, hoppas jag.
Och det tycker jag att man ska kunna vara online också, då tror jag att det blir jävligt spännande.
Och så är ju alla där inne online på sajten med sina avatarer och har sådana Gucci-väskor.
Och du vet.
Jag fattar, var du en av de som blev irriterad när Facebook körde sin meta universe-grej och det inte riktigt slog där?
Du hoppade, eller du tänker fortfarande på den?
Nej, nej, nej.
Men det var ju så mycket en VR-grej.
Det var en jävla missuppfattning av vad metaverse är egentligen.
VR är ju bara en skärm.
Det har inte med det att göra överhuvudtaget.
Det handlar ju om hur man är den digitala versionen av en själv, online.
Exakt, den digitala personligheten.
Ja, precis.
Hur det representeras.
Det är skithäftigt för mig.
Här finns det ju massor med trösklar, och det har jag alltid funnits trösklar när det gäller avatar generellt.
Nu är det många av våra kunder som använder dem.
Det är inte alls som det var förr, det har ändrats jättemycket.
Jag vet inte riktigt vad det beror på egentligen, men det har ju sett sig som något väldigt barnsligt, tror jag.
Du tycker säkert att det är barnsligt också med avatar i barnen.
Min flickvän använder det.
Var använder hon det då?
De skickar sina såna här, du vet, hon har en egen liten avatar, när hon skickar med henne så syns det att hon...
En egen liten telefon?
Nej men den ser ut som henne, jag vet inte vilka chatten hon använder, men då skickar hon ju såhär, det är hon själv som gör en tumme upp, den ser ut som det här.
Jag som sagt, jag fattar inte det.
Men folk använder ju vuxna människor och...
Men du har en mobiltelefon va?
Den här mobiltelefonen har jag.
Men du vet alla telefoner, har du en iPhone eller vad du nu har för någonting liksom?
Och Apple har ju, de har ju flera miljarder användare, det är inte bara kids som använder Apple-produkter.
Så det är ett mysterium för mig varför det har varit så stigmatiserat och varför det har sett som så barnsligt.
Det där är en sån extremt stor grej.
Jag tycker att det ska bli jävligt spännande att se.
Jag är ju alltid skeptisk till allting men jag är ju inte...
När jag ser att saker funkar så hoppar jag på liksom.
Ni är inte med med det.
Men du, jag har sparat in din site.
Lite grann.
Jag har lite...
Ja, vad gör vi casta?
Du får avbryta när du vill nu.
Nu har vi kört på er.
Men säg vad vi gör dåligt, det hade varit roligt.
Nej, nej, nej.
Ni är ju fantastiska.
Nu ska vi inte sälja in oss.
Om du inte fick sälja dig så får fan inte vi sälja oss heller.
Så bara kritik nu.
Okej, jag kollade på era produktdesignationer.
Har du koll på dem?
Jag hoppas det.
Det är jag som godkänner alla.
Men hur ser de ut på produktstiden?
Ja, vad oroliga jag blir när du säger så.
Berätta bara.
Det är ett spännande sätt att göra det bara.
Jag vill vänta.
Säg vad som är så dåligt nu.
Det är kul att du har stjärnor för pris och för de två olika stjärnorna.
Ja exakt, pris och kvalitet.
Och så ger vi ett snitt på dem.
Pris och kvalitet, intressant.
Varför är det intressant?
Jag menar om det behövs.
Det ser lite dubbelt ut bara eller?
Ja men det är för att, så som vi resonerar det till exempel, du kan ju ha en produkt som är halvkass, om du tar en bänk som kostar 1000 spänn, den kommer vara lite skranglig.
Priset kan vara skitbra, det är svinbra pris, men kvaliteten är en trea.
Då blir snittet, det är en fyra och det är rimligt för den produkten.
Men du har ju i princip så är det fem, alltid på båda.
Det är så här, ja va fan, kom igen du kan liknande.
Jag gick in på första produkt när jag gick in på, då hade vi fem på pris, fyra på kvalitet.
Den andra hade vi tre på kvalitet, tre fem på pris.
Den hade vi två på kvalitet, fyra på pris.
Inte en enda produkt hade vi det på som jag kollar på nu.
Av de fem jag kollar på, fan vad gött.
Det är en produkt, det är en produkt.
Varför är alla produktrecessioner skrivna med versaler?
Varför är det bara stora uppställningar?
Som att skrika ut sina recensioner.
Fan vilken bra produkt!
Är det för att det är...
Det här är inte favoritsegment i den här podden någonsin.
Jag bara undrar, är det för att det ska vara såhär...
Jag tror att det är för att vi aldrig har reflekterat över det här någonsin.
Det var en jävligt bra poäng.
Nej, nej, nej, nej, nej.
Det är en sak som någon utifrån måste säga.
Ja, ja, det står ju så.
Det är helt sjukt.
Vet inte riktigt vad de andra recensionerna syftar på.
Va mycket bra, Arus!
Jag älskar den här produkten!
Fem stjärnor pris, fem stjärnor kvalitet.
Ja, helt rätt.
Det är helt sjukt, jag fattar ingenting.
Men jag tror att ni hade inte behövt ha det liksom.
Nej, det hade vi nog inte behövt ha.
Men jag undrar om det var medvetet?
Nej, det är inte medvetet.
Det är bara vi som har fuckat upp.
Det är roligt, det är roligt.
Ja, vi ska stänga det så att lite folk behöver lyssna på oss längre.
Jag tror att detta är min nya favoritintervju.
Jag ska tänka igenom den.
Vi ska tänka igenom den på verk.
Om jag hade någon annan ultrafavorit hemma.
Fan vad roligt det var.
Stort, stort tack för att du var med i podden och för att du var liksom dig själv.
Tack för att du fick vara med.
Men folk får väl sparken?
Vd-ar får väl sparken än?
Jo, det kanske de får men inte om man går från 100 miljoner till 2 miljarder får man väl inte sparken.
Okej, om man går från 2 miljarder till 100 miljoner, det är en helt annan situation.